with colliders Oh Margo I just want to
ask you first so in being producer on
this film can you talk about the
difference between being on say on this
one versus on the Suicide Squad I think
we met a very different version of
Holley and Suicide Squad and now she's
in a different stage of her life and I
think the most differential fact
differentiating differentiating factor
with the Joker they break up at the
beginning of the movie and she's not
okay with it even though she would tell
you that she is so that puts in her a
place of vulnerability to begin with and
wishing her kind of act out and even
more erratic ways than usual I think but
also the fact that she's the narrator in
this film kind of colors the viewers
experience because you are seeing things
from her point of view and being given
kind of her opinion on things whether
she's right or wrong most of the case
she's wrong but she jumps around in the
story and she forgets to introduce you
to people and you know it's it's a
colorful world it's a side of Gotham
that we haven't seen before
true we truly have not seen anything
like this for all of you guys can you
just talk about what was your favorite
aspect and find trying to find your
character and portraying your character
sure I mean working working with Margo
and Chris and everybody on set it was
just it was so amazing and I think with
finding Cassandra Cain I really had to
figure out who she was and her story in
her background and I did base it a lot
off of the comics and I worked a lot
with Kathy and her notes and then other
than that there wasn't really anything
in the film industry in the film aspect
where Cassandra Cain wasn't really
represented so I felt this big
responsibility to take that head-on you
absolutely killed it what about you did
you know Margo was a big inspiration I
really watched her on set and because
we're both playing these you know
larger-than-life characters and I
watched Suicide Squad to kind of find
the tone of what was too big what
too small so yeah and of course the
comics were really helpful as well and
so can you just talk about because you
guys all had some really intense
challenging scenes you just talked about
when some of the most challenging things
you remember like one set filming
orgeous scenes that stick out to you
from just because they were also more
fun memories we had a lot of fun I think
the one time that all of us are in a
scene together is in the safe house and
it's kind of like that the time the
moment where you see all the elements
collide everyone's disparate storylines
collide in a pretty insane way and it
was just so fun to be able to do that
together it was all sort of like a ton
of dialogue but often in these kinds of
films you don't get to do that much
dialogue all at once and I I don't know
I really loved that is one of my
favorite moments yeah I feel like it was
so fun and crazy that like it's a
full-on rainbow and I feel like if you
could pull in like a zoo with like
elephants and giraffes it would have
been just as fine like it would have
felt the same energy yeah that that
scene in particular was that the
funhouse was really it was that was a
fun see that was my audition scene with
the when Mia martyr or there on the
couch and I remember thinking during
that scene that I wanted to I don't know
why this was this was in my head but
that might might would my name was
Victor Harry she says I don't know why
that that help that I wanted that to be
my middle name you just talk about what
it's like working with Ewan McGregor and
him trying to become black mask y'all
two together that was just crazy talk
about that yeah it was great you know
he's such a lovely guy he's so funny and
charming and then on a dime he goes
really violent in this movie and it was
fun to be this his henchmen who just was
obsessed with him and yeah I loved him
I've loved him since Trainspotting and
so I was just a great honor to work with
him and what about you Margaret
same thing Trainspotting was a bit of a
reference for Christina and I when we
were first talking about you know what
we wanted to achieve with this film you
know four years ago or whatever one of
the main things that I really wanted to
pull off was to not let it feel like it
had that three act formulaic structure
that I was starting to become so
accustomed to it can kind of like end
now we're gonna have the second I'm flow
point and now yeah you know it's it you
can kind of predict what's gonna happen
so a movie like Trainspotting which has
you know it feels chaotic yet it is
always satisfying when you break it down
it actually fits a three-hour structure
perfectly but it doesn't feel like that
so it's a movie we always had in our
head and then you and came on board
years later and it was just kind of yeah
we were incredibly grateful well thank
you guys so much for talking with me I
had incredible blast with the movie and
I can't wait for more people to see it
oh thanks thank you guys